biggest challenge we're facing the risk
of permanent scarring of young people a
lost generation just an unacceptable
that's going to store up enormous social
political and economic damage of the
future we have to find a solution to
actually give young people home now and
feel the need to have a guarantee you've
jobs packed when young people have an
opportunity of either training skills in
quality internship or a job placing
within six months of being unemployed is
one initiative which governments
business and social partners really have
to put together now beyond that we have
to create more jobs there's no point of
just sacking adults and saying we're
going to employ their children at a
lower wage that has to be an overall
strategy now for prioritizing job
creation as the key problem has to be
resolved in this in this economic crisis